[Musik]
guten tag gehe auf einem bergpfad mit 99
kurven geradeaus mit solchen sätzen
meditiert man im zentrum des buddhismus
und ja sie sind verwirrend aber mein
heutiger gast ist zen meister und jesuit
niklaus brantschen er weiß wie man auf
einem solchen pfad mit 99 kurve
geradeaus geht oder herr branchen
topscorer schritt um schritt atemzug um
ort im zug und dann kommt man geradeaus
und da kommen wir noch den gipfel dann
kommt man zum ziel
was ist denn der sinn dieser sogenannten
korns dieser doch oft sehr
unverständlichen ja fast schon paradox
einsetzen korn helfen einem aus der
illusion des getrennt science
herauszukommen der trennen ja gerne
subjekt objekt sinnen außen sich welt
und die tatsache ist das alles eins ist
verbunden vernetzt
das listet das wissen die bäume die
verbinden sich unter der erde
das weiß dass betteln denken wir anden
entdeckt ein schmetterling löst
verändert das wetter aus und zwar sind
wir verbunden vernetzt 1 und seien wir
durch diese komischen setzte hindurch
auf diese einheit hin uns in bewegung
bleiben
jetzt sitzen wir hier ja auch in einem
zehnten meditationsraum im bad
schönbrunn im langhaus sie haben das
mitbegründet haben das ganz lange auch
geleitet das vergangene jahr hat uns
geprägt durch stille vielleicht auch
innerlichkeit im grunde genommen wäre
das doch eine extrem gute zeit um 10 zu
üben oder außerdem setzt eben von außen
aufgedrückt ist sie sagen dem grund
genommen und für viele ist es auch so
für viele ist diese auferlegte auszeit
eine chance dass sie weniger reisen mehr
zeit haben wir zeit haben für die pflege
der die innerlichkeit es gibt die
anderen für die ist es sehr schwierig
diese zeit der isolation die
unsicherheit die probleme die damit
verbunden sind auch häusliche art
finanzieller art aber es gibt andere die
sagen die wir in dieser zeit nicht mehr
zu mir gefunden
das finde ich ganz spannend was jetzt
ansprechen weil genau den eindruck habe
ich auch es gibt doch die stille die
einem auch reicher macht zum beispiel
eben wenn man hier für längere zeit
schweigt eben und dann die stille die
viele leute auch zu hause erlebt haben
die mit einsamkeit verbunden wird das
ist eine qualitative differenz ja es
gibt verschiedene qualitäten gestelle
also das einmal kommen unterscheiden
zwischen vereinsamung einsam und stille
das ist nicht dasselbe allein sein heißt
noch nicht weiß ich sein
es kann zur vereinsamung führen allein
sein kann aber auch zu sich führen und
dann gibt es da noch einmal verschiedene
typen de still es gibt die so genannte
ich nenne das geführte stimme wenn man
es so still ist hier zur ruhe kommen
so wie jetzt jeder in diesem raum
aber es gibt sozusagen noch eine stimme
hinter der darsteller die wir nicht
begreifen kann nicht erfassen könne die
umfängt uns die begreift und fast uns
die größe und das ist dass man sie
vorhin sagte mit der dimension in die
wir hinein reichen im schweigen in der
übung oder einheit ist kein kommen und
kein
gehen kein vorher und ein nachher raum
freiheit freiheit oder eben noch stille
und um diese stille geht es im letzten
also um die stille hinter der stelle
letztlich so zu sorgen wie haben sie
denn für sich selber die stille entdeckt
als eben auch schatz
es braucht zeit es braucht zeit aber ich
darf sagen ich hatte eine gewisse
affinität zur stelle
durch meine herkunft in den bergen
sie kommen ja aus dem aus dem dorf
randalen matan im wallis im oberwallis
und da gibt es berge und wenn man sich
bewegen kann man nur die wände hoch
sozusagen die hänge hoch und ich bin
viel allein wurde mit hunden unterwegs
gewesen wanderungen gemacht so wie ich
am anfang sagte da habe ich schritte
machen gelernt schritt um schritt
atemzug und zuckt da habe ich eine erste
affinität zur stelle bekommen
jetzt ist doch die stille im zentis muss
auch so wichtig weil die meditationsform
auch ohne gedanken ohne worte ohne
bilder
gewissermaßen ist also es geht auch um
ein radikales nichts heißt das im
umkehrschluss dass die dass die sprache
uns vor der versenkung hindert die
sprache nicht unbedingt aber das gerede
und das getue und das gehabe
wenn ich darauf aus bin ständig zu
balladen trieben etwas zu tun und zu
haben dann komm ich keinen schritt
weiter weil das eine andere qualität ist
das meditieren rest dieses tun das
äußere tun vorübergehend los geht in die
absolute freiheit des teams in das nicht
tun auch nicht sein und aus diese lehre
wie wir im sender sagen unendlichkeit
schöpfen wir aus dem nichts kommt etwas
neues
ich habe mich gefragt weil genau ja die
die stille auch verschiedene qualitäten
einem hat was mögen sie lieber die
stille des frühen morgens oder die
stille der nacht
das sollte das habe ich mich nie gefragt
beides hat seine seiner qualität in der
free endlich aufwachen und etwas jetzt
die vögel würde dann stört dass eben
dieser stelle nicht sondern
unterstreicht sozusagen die stille und
der abend in der dämmerung wenn der tag
hinter mir liegt ist auch ist auch okay
stille ist dann keine tageszeit geworden
denkt man keiner nach zu halt wenn sie
tief genug ist können sie möchte ich es
aber was jetzt gesagt haben heißt nur
der mensch macht lernen die tiere machen
keinen lärm sehr gut gesagt ich denke
die tiere bewegen sich die machen
geräusche
das verhalten das knackt wenn sie laufen
das ist nicht lernt lernt entsteht wenn
wir etwas tun was nicht so ganz uns in
unserem innersten entspricht wenn wir
herum wursteln hantieren aber ein
ruhiges arbeiten
bricht die stelle nicht stirpe stelle
nicht wenn ich mir im haus mit ihr auch
mit gruppen und es wird etwa dass
ausgerechnet man hört so einen besen
irgendwo an einer wand antippen das
gehört zum tagesablauf aber lärm
entsteht denn in ihren finden etwas als
lernen wenn es so
lustig ist gehetzt und ruhig und
motiviert ja es ist manchmal mühsam wenn
man sie so reden hört dann fragt man
sich suchen sie sich die freunde auch
danach aus wie gut sie mit ihnen
schweigen können sich nicht bewusst aber
sicher ist werde ich das jetzt so zu mir
ne ne ist die schweizer gegner beim
laufen zb mit gruppen oder auch zu zweit
im posten auch eine viertelstunde dann
eine halbe stunde ist speichern dabei
und kann dass ihre begleiter gut und das
ist gut und das verbindet verbindet mehr
als wenn ständig geredet wird
das ist so eine qualität eine schwingung
der verbundenheit mit der stimme aus
qualität verbindet die nach etwas
gespräch verendet dem gespräch mehr
tiefe gibt neue wendungen wenn stiller
verbindet dann müssten jetzt
gewissermaßen ein stilles gespräch
führen bestenfalls oder wenn wir uns
miteinander verbinden wollen aber wir
haben vorhin fordern begehen wir uns
schon hingesetzt waren in der maske sehr
ruhig sehr still und das verbindet wir
sind so verschieden vor elen schießen
kommt anders ich bin ganz anders aber
durch dieses schweigen des und runter
verbindet auch entsteht gemeinsamkeit
und einzigartigkeit und wir sind nicht
nur eins wir sind verschieden und dank
der erfahrung der einheit in
verschiedenheit auch einzigartig das
erinnert mich dann wieder an das korn
von vom beginn
ich habe mich eben gefragt dass ein
stilles gespräch führen das ist ja auch
schon etwas paradoxes in einem gewissen
sinne könnte das auch ein korn sein oder
zuschauer hat mir im vorfeld auch
geschrieben was macht denn eigentlich
einen koran satz aus kann jeder einen
solchen satz produzieren oder wie
erkennt man
richtiges korn das leben ist voller korn
volle spannungsgeladene setzte zum
beispiel frag ich sage jetzt ein anderes
gewohnt was war ihr angesicht bevor ihre
eltern geboren wurden
die bahn vor derzeit gelten
und da merkte plötzlich wenn sie das
lösen das etwas ihnen ist das unzerstört
mann ist das nicht an zeit gebunden ist
wie erkannt sagt er übrigens von sem ist
sehr ernst
viel studiert wird meister rk hat das
ist etwas anders sehe das nicht
geschaffen wurde und nicht zerstört
werden kann
das ist das was bleibt was ewig ist und
das ist so an an korn die lese ich dass
wir für mich dass ich fit bin aber wie
lösen sie das wie haben sie das gelöst
im stillen sitzen oder auf wanderungen
offenbar auch jetzt sind sie ja nicht
nur zehn meister sondern sie sind auch
jesuit was sehen sie denn konkret aus
das verbinden der der christlichen
spiritualität und das sein weil für mich
intuitiv denke ich an zum beispiel gott
als fülle wie er im barock gefeiert wird
mit doch auch einer verglichen jetzt mit
mit dem 10 wo werden die wir zuvor
besprochen haben was auch um das nichts
geht um die lehre
das ist für mich ein widerspruch das
kann als widerspruch erscheinen entweder
oder aber demselben gibt es eben nicht
widerspreche sie sind philosophen sie
kennen das biete spruchs prinzip wie
geht das
was meinen sie dass an den
ausgeschlossenen dritten also entweder
ja oder nein gleichermaßen genau
entweder ja oder nein des todes im
sinnes nicht entweder ja oder nein da
ist rund also ein beispiel da kommt eine
zu einem kleinen beerdigung und sag ist
tot sagt er ja kommt ein anderer lebt er
da kommt die antwort ja oder ein anderes
wort am ende der zeiten wird es ist groß
geschrieben vergehen der antwort ja es
vergeht alles geht in einem anderen korn
als das wenn die zeit vorbei ist wird es
das umfassend wird das ganze auch
verschwinden nein es bleibt je nach dem
je nach dem offensichtlich hat das leben
ein ende
es steht dort wird dann habe und auch
mieter das ist eine herausforderung ist
zu erfahren
es ist etwas was unzerstörbar ist es
bleibt und insofern ja und nein und
vielleicht noch der erste schritt der
nach japan kam franz hat er derart lange
diskutiert mit einem sagt wiebe tod und
auferstehung uns heute schreibt
zurücktransferiert eigenartig diesem
entschied so hieß der münchen
er sagt manchmal ja manchmal ein
aber er ist mein freund jetzt haben sie
es aber elegant gelöst trotzdem wenn sie
jetzt uns ein beispiel geben möchten wo
genau sie selber in ihrem auch lebens
vorzügen dieser ganzen begegnung auch
mit dem zähnen sie waren ja oft auch in
japan wo sehen sie denn konkret dass das
verbindende das verbindende zum beispiel
auch zum für mich als jetzt wieder ist
das totale radikale ernst nehmen um der
tat also sein bleibt nicht in der die
innerlichkeit steckt das ist auch ein
grund warum wir mit offenen augen
meditieren wir schließen nicht hier
ziehen uns nicht in die innerlichkeit
zurück nach der übung ja aber dann
kommen die übung fertig stehen wir auf
und stellen uns der situation der
wickelt hat ganz großes ernst nehmen von
allem an jedem von jedem detail und das
entspricht den autos von lola der
wirklich durch gelange schulung auch
durch eine tiefe erfahrung die ähnlich
ist wie eine zen erfahrung überall und
in allem gott gefunden hat man kann gott
sagt er über land sind und ich sage
montiert man kann gott überall finden
sogar sind kaputt es ist wunderbar jetzt
frage ich mich trotzdem sehen sie nicht
dass es auch ein problem gewissermaßen
geben könnte von einer vereinnahmung
vielleicht sogar von einer form von
kolonialisierung von einer anderen
kultur
das ist bestimmt ein vorwurf den sie
auch oft hören wird weil sie das so
verbinden auch hier im haus genau ich
hole ganz kurz aus wir sind wir im
zentrum im meditationsraum den habe ich
vor 15 jahren eingerichtet eine neue
positionierung da kam ein französischer
mit bruder sah dies in rom und sagte ja
seht ihr die chance da wurde sorgen dass
der vorraum fürs eigentliche und dann
sagte ich noch zu den chance die
verbauung hat gültigkeit im sich für
sich und dann im selben haus unter
demselben dach eine katholische kapelle
das ordnen wir zu aber es ist nicht
sozusagen instrumentalisiert dass sein
sohn als instrument dient um das
christentum auf zu melden da wär ich
mich da geld sondern es sind zwei
möglichkeiten die zwei hände nehmen wir
mal ost und west
und die kommen zusammen nichts weil
nicht als ist die formel 2 1 oder die
hände von anderen gebieten dem einst
kopierte hertie von der und dieser hände
sind so zum verblüffend ähnlich oder
selber die das gas das kachunga show
heißt wirklich aneinandergelegt der
händler wird im sinn immer wieder
benutzt ein ausdruck dass respekt der
achtung voreinander
wenn ich mich verdienen verbeuge ist das
ein ausdruck der dankbarkeit der achtung
und so diese haltung ob in ost oder west
vollzogen ist menschlich und auf diesen
lägen auf diesen einfachen
ausdrucksweisen begegnen wir uns nicht
in der theorie da gibt es unterschiede
aber im ganz alltäglichen vollzug und
hindern diskussion im interreligiösen
dialoges gittern gibt den
interreligiösen zwischengegner menschen
und dann gibt es in uns eine begegnung
einen dialog da merkt man plötzlich das
kommt zusammen das macht uns weiter und
ganz alleine
der andere teil meiner seele nämlich die
österreicher kommt zum zug
sie sagen ja oft wenn sie darauf
angesprochen werden wie sie den halt
nichts mit zehn gekommen sind dass sie
eben nicht als frustrierter priester
zusammengekommen sind
das ist ihm offenbar sehr wichtig zu
betonen weshalb liegt weshalb ist dieser
aspekt ihnen so wichtig ich betone es
würden die menschen fragen ja warum hat
dir etwas gefehlt in dem kontext und da
habe ich gesagt man mir nicht gefällt
sondern eher die neugierde was tut sich
auf der anderen hälfte der welt die welt
anders gesagt wächst zusammen ost und
west begegnen sich jung hat noch vor
wenigen tagen
jahrzehnten gesagt der geist des ostens
steht vor der tür
heute steht er in unserem zimmer und er
sagte auch vielleicht ist es eine
infektion und vielleicht ein heilmittel
und da kann man jetzt schauen probieren
für mich war das ein mittel anhalt
mitteln ganz zu werden
sie sprechen ja oft von zehn auch davon
dass es wie bergsteigen sei da habe ich
mich gefragt was sieht man dann vom 10
gipfel aus das wissen sie ja als zehn
meist also der vergleich ist die übung
der übung ist sehr ähnlich
überhaupt stehen in der gruppe bewegen
schritt um schritt wird und zu kommen
hatte im zuge der atem ist ganz wichtig
in einem fall haben sie aussicht
im andern 1
das ist sehr schön
sie erzählen aber sehr wenig darüber wie
sie selber priester geworden sind das
hat eben auch mit dem bergsteigen zu tun
sagen sie jedenfalls erhängt es hängt
auch mit ihrem ältesten bruder zusammen
der beim bergsteigen verunfallt ist oder
ja das war wie ich war damals 18 das war
ein unverschämter herbst bank der sarg
war aufgebaut ein dorf auf dem platz und
da kam mir der gedanke was soll dieses
leben
warum lebe ich wozu und dann später hat
mich festgestellt dass auch zen
buddhisten oft durch den frühen tod
eines bruders oder einer mutter diesen
weg gefunden haben das sind so schock
therapien wo man sagt ja vielleicht ist
ein anderer weg für mich als der übliche
der richtige und dann habe ich ihn
gewählt und das hat zu spenden hat das
hat sich bewährt waren also das heißt
aber dieses schockerlebnis hat sie dahin
geführt aber das ist ja die entscheidung
wirklich auch als priester zu leben in
diesem orden der jesuiten auch zu
bleiben das ist eher ein ziemlich langer
weg oder es ist eine entscheidung die
ich mit 22 sehr jungen
und dann ist ein lange bild des vertraut
werdens mit dem geist des ignatius durch
studien durch spirituelle praktiken dann
eine ergänzende studien waren
aufenthalte in japan sei es ist dann 1
wegen der dort wo ich jetzt bin und mein
glück und da bin ich ewig dankbar mein
glück war dass ein älterer jesuit
zuständig war für mich gesagt hat du
könntest eigentlich nach japan und das
ließ ich mir nich zweimal sagen ich bin
gegangen und immer wieder
und noch einmal und so hat das einen aus
zwei butter 1 können sich erinnern
weshalb sie denn genau die jesuiten also
weshalb ignatius von loyola weshalb
diese dieser orten und nicht ein anderer
hätte es keine ahnung
ein motiv war die weltoffenheit des
jesuitenordens ist jetzt sehr gut
zusammen passt es gibt klöster mönche
die mauern haben konnten das nicht her
zurückziehen die warten bis die leute zu
ihnen kommen die betonen die
gastfreundschaft des witten ist wenn du
eine apostolische horden wir warten
nicht wir gehen zu den deutschen
wir gehen zu den leuten da wo sie sind
und holen sie darauf wo sie sind ja nun
leben sie ja schon seit bald fünf
jahrzehnten hier eben im bad schönbrunn
im logenhaus sie haben hier eben auch
gelehrt und so weiter das haus ist nicht
nur speziell wegen diesem zuvor
angesprochenen brückenschlag zwischen
christlicher spiritualität und östlicher
spiritualität sozusagen sondern auch
aufgrund der architektur man sieht es
schon um uns herum man nennt das auch
harmonie kahle bauweise und wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe geht es darum
dass die architektur auf den menschen
wirken soll es so wie musik zum beispiel
auch auf den menschen der merkten sie
diese wirkung wohl wie wird es denn
also einmal es wird mir auch nach 50
jahren in diesem haus nicht langweilig
es ist nicht kaserne links und rechts
zimmer und mit dem eingang
es ist durchkomponiertes harmonie kahle
bauweise heißt der architekt hat er ein
saiteninstrument im büro zupfte hörte
komponierte
das klingt effektiv dort also ist dieses
haus ein musikstück ja kann man so sagen
und je besser es ist ein instrument und
wir bespielen das ja also der einzelnen
bespielte sie heiß aber hören sie ja
auch trompete raus ich habe nämlich
gelesen dass die trompetenkonzerte mögen
das hat eine bestimmte bank ist das bei
meiner geburt der vater trompete
gespielt hat wir haben gelegentlich
konzerte im großen saal rocken
das könnte es kriegt aber das klingt
doch ohne instrumente es ist es ist
hörbar und dann kommt noch dazu dass das
haus wie sind die landschaft hinein
gebaut wurde mit zwei armen es ist dann
kreis aber nicht geschlossener kreis
geschlossener kreis werde abschluss
offene kreis das heißt wir schließen uns
nicht ab sondern wir öffnen uns und da
gibt es räume die diese die sind maximal
geschlossen und die hallen sind weit
offen und auch hier öffnen und schließen
innen und außen verwendet sich auch da
eine gemeinsamkeit zur spiritualität das
sind und auf die trompete noch
zurückkommen weil mich das noch
interessiert hat dieses dass sie dieses
blasinstrument offenbar auch so mögen
sie haben selber auch trompete zu lernen
begonnen oder wie steht es da sicher
auch blockiert
begonnen aber noch rechtzeitig aufgehört
das heißt sie haben es nicht
weitergeführt also sie werden uns kein
ständchen spielen
ein anderer punkt der nicht sehr
interessiert an ihnen sie haben ja
dieses buch geschrieben mit hilfe ihres
tagebuchs haben ein leben lang tagebuch
geschrieben
ich bewundere das weil ich das selber
irgendwie bis jetzt nicht hingekriegt
habe immer wenn ich mich hinsetze und
etwas notieren möchte befremdet mich das
irgendwie ich entgleite mir da selbst
dann habe ich mich gefragt jetzt wo sie
das selber so lange gemacht haben wie
haben sie das wirklich gemacht und waren
sie immer ganz ehrlich oder haben sie da
auch idealisiert also ich lasse mich
leiten von der jüdischen dichterin rose
ausländer den tag ist mein buch also
tagebuch ist mein buch hier trage ich
mein leben ein
an dem ich mich erfreuen dass ich leute
alles liebe es und leides von heute und
mühe und not trage ich ein
und jetzt neue denkt sie haben nach der
stimmung der stille am morgen und am
abend gefragt
allerdings schreibe ich das tagebuch am
morgen leute nicht mehr zitiert habe
gefrühstückt aber setze ich mich hin
schaue auf den vergangenen tag zurück
und dann halte ich fest was so war und
es hilft mir dankbar zu sein
immer wieder kommt dann im tagebuch mein
gott habe ich grund dankbar zu sein und
schreibt dann danke danke danke ich
denke dass ich morgen früh wenn ich das
tagebuch schreibe auch bezug nehmen
werde
auf dieses unseres gespräch und dann
hoffentlich auch mit danke ich hoffe
dass es dass es hier ein angenehmes
gespräch ist sie haben eben auch gesagt
das hilft ihnen bewusster zu leben das
kann ich natürlich sehr gut verstehen
ich habe mich dann gefragt wenn sie eben
dieses buch 2017 mit hilfe dieses dieser
tagebuch geschrieben haben
wie war das für sie
diesen kleinen niklaus brantschen wieder
zu wiederzutreffen gewissermaßen
ich habe mir viel zeit dafür genommen
und bin so laufen gegangen und dann
kamen so einzelne szenen mechanischen
buch festgehalten wo ich mich wie von
außen gesehen habe als ein junge der so
und so und so gehandelt hat und dann
merkst du habe ich gemerkt dass dieser
junge von damals hin mehr ist
der ist nicht weg zum beispiel habe ich
sehr gern bin ich sehr gerne bezeichnet
erklettert und und das ist geblieben ich
klettere heute noch überzeugt
nein wenn es irgendwie geht es ist
niemals zu schauen sollten bleiben ich
würde eigentlich gerne zuschauen wie sie
da einfach über diese wie sie zäune
klettern
aber das heißt sie haben sich selber
wieder erkannt in diesen alten noch
notizen ja es ist nicht so dass sicher
doch ganz anders bin aus jetzt alles
nicht wahr sondern das ist alles in uns
eingetroffen
wir beruhige auf den wurzeln der tor
fahren aber auch auf den wurzeln die wir
in jungen jahren geschlagen haben die
tragen uns genauso
sie sind inzwischen 83 jahre alt das ist
eine ziemlich lange lebenszeit haben sie
im laufe der dauer verstanden was zeit
ist nah dass da bin ich immer noch dran
und ich habe viele antworten aber da hat
augustinus sich den kopf zerbrochen dann
viele andere
mein zugang ist ein wort von angelus
silesius zeit ist die ewigkeit und je
sich kite die zeit so du nur selber
nicht
most einen unterschied zeit die ewigkeit
und ewigkeit wie zeit und wenn ich das
so auf mich wirken lassen und dann stehe
dann komme ich in einer präsenz hinein
wo diese gemessene zeit und der raum
derzeit freiheit im befüllten augenblick
zusammenkommen und dann bin ich präsent
anwesend und ich hoffe verlassen für sie
interessant uhr
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich branchen
für dieses schöne gespräch ja wir
bleiben gleich beim 10 und nehmen sie
mit nach japan genauer gesagt nach kyoto
dort steht der bekannte und berühmte
daichi tempel eine filmische entdeckung
oder vielleicht sogar erleuchtung haben
sie einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]
warum jetzt
[Gelächter]